i want to end on this statistic which i
learned
last year and has really become one of
my north stars
researchers at the family acceptance
project at san francisco state
university
one question they're asked is do you
believe that you will ever be
a happy lgbt adult for queer youth who
come from families rated extremely
accepting
92 percent 92 are able to imagine
themselves in happy futures
for queer youth from families who who
outright
shun or reject them only 35 have this
ability
think about that for a minute two-thirds
of lgbtq young people
who had the misfortune to be born to
families that cannot accept them
have lost the ability to imagine their
future selves being happy
i can't see how losing that ability is
any different from losing one's
fundamental sense of hope hope for
themselves hope for the world
hope for their for their individual
future or ours collectively
so it's phenomenal like this that
happened every day
anywhere an lgbtq kid is growing up
knowing that they're different
afraid to express it even in the most
progressive regions let alone the most
conservative
that motivates me to keep querying the
future and showing that the future can
be
queer to create more scenarios with
thriving queer protagonists
to uncover the trends that will
particularly impact lgbtq people
not just to preempt emerging victimhood
but also to empower them to grab the
wheel
and grab us by the future they see and
deserve